for those of you who don't know
Smallville is actually the story of
Superman before he was Superman
actually met someone who didn't know
that so now you know Smallville
now this is a weird review for me
because I was a huge fan of Smallville
when it came out I watched it like all
the time cuz I love seeing Lex Luthor
when he was young in Clark Kent when he
was young they're all friends and you
just know that Lex Luthor is gonna
become bad that is awesome and then
Michael Rosenbaum the actor who played
Lex Luthor in Smallville didn't renew
his contract after the seventh season so
he just kind of went away after that I
was like what is the point so I stopped
watching after that and yeah the
character Lex Luthor reappeared wearing
a mask or something like that but it
wasn't Michael Rosenbaum he is the best
Lex Luthor ever put on screen I'm
telling you ever but for the last season
I was like I invested seven years into
this I didn't watch the last two seasons
but I'm watching the last season because
I want to see the dude become Superman
and so was it worth it
yeah actually for me it was really worth
it first of the show Smallville has had
its ups and downs
my favorite was season five because in
season five they introduced Brainiac
played by Spike from Buffy and Angel
dude was an awesome Brainiac he was just
like this really smart guy and Clark was
out of high school at that point so it
stopped feeling like teen romance
[ __ ] even though she still made it
feel like that sometimes a lot of times
Lana got really annoying she was stupid
but season five was it for me then
season six concentrated on Lex and Lana
having a relationship and it got back to
stupid teen drama in fact Lana pissed me
off so much and annoyed me so much and
now she's a pivotal part of the plot it
was dumb and on to season 10 season 10
of Smallville is a great origin story
for Superman for me like I've always
said Superman is really hard to do
because he is so super and so in that he
can go one of two ways he can either be
the shiny example of what you should be
you know someone to look up to because
you're like it's possible to be like
that or you can be so damn super you're
like he's beyond me I don't care I just
don't relate to that luckily Smallville
did it the relatable way and season 10
dropped all of the stupid romance
[ __ ] this is the story of Clark Kent
becoming Superman and they brought
Darkseid into it everyone knows Darkseid
for me Darkseid was always my favorite
Superman villain I mean Zod is really
iconic but he's been used like a hundred
times Darkseid though man did his
business I mean there are many aspects
of how someone like Clark Kent become
Superman
so the whole time you're waiting you
know in the last episode you're like
dudes going to fly come on cuz
contract that said no tights no flight
stupid sounding contract but you get the
point no Superman suit no flying and at
a point in season 10 he was like in
order to be a beacon of light and hope
for people you can't wear a mask so it
gave a rhyme and reason as to why he's a
hero who doesn't wear a mask but he
wears the Clark Kent mask and that's
awesome I mean in this new Superman
movie that's coming out next year I
don't see how they're going to touch on
all the aspects of how Clark Kent become
Superman now like I said in the end of
Smallville yes he does get the suit he
does fly however I wish they showed it
more and that's not a spoiler I mean the
writers in like season 1 said that that
was gonna happen in the end but I wish
they showed more of him in the suit I
wanted a really good full head-to-toe
body shot of him in the suit but it's
always like I had a distance and CGI or
it shows just his face with the cape
flapping behind him or something but the
last three to five minutes of the
episode brought it all home for me you
have no idea how much that Superman tone
ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ow you know that
you have no idea how much weight that
song holds once that song starts
swelling and coming on you're like dude
it is it and the last shot is just
iconic Superman after that I was like I
this is like the definitive origin story
for me Clark Kent just became Superman
in fact after the show I think it would
be really cool for them to do like a
Superman show with the Smallville cast
there's more to do why not in the end if
we're just talking about season 10 cause
I know some of you out there haven't
seen the whole Smallville show or you're
like my little sister watches that [ __ ]
why would I
I understand but when Smallville is
really good it is really good in its
source when it's high school [ __ ] it
is absolutely high school stupid weird
[ __ ] but it is those two worlds it's
like it's it's own Clark Kent and
Superman I would say if you haven't seen
Smallville see Season ten at least
you're going to be a little lost because
they try to incorporate a lot of the
other seasons into it I mean there was
some stuff that happened in the last two
seasons that they're talking about in
here I'm like I don't know what that is
but I move on but season 10 it's worth
checking out do it I'm telling you when
it wrapped up I was like this is cool
[ __ ] props to the writers for pulling
that off that's cool so did you watch
Smallville did you watch like a couple
of seasons then drop it quit after
season seven like me after Lex left did
you watch the whole thing did you watch
just season ten were you happy with it
did you like how it ended comment below
let me know and if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you